[Music]
this time it's finally time here we go
today's a big day because in February of
2011 we started this little channel
called Sam and Nico featuring yours
truly and his truly but you know why
it's been a few years and since then the
team has grown it's not really about us
anymore it's about everyone here it's
about the whole crew that's right we
have a whole film crew here whole group
of people that help us make our videos
and run a YouTube channel unlike any
other YouTube channel on YouTube and
it's been quite an adventure it's time
that we reflect that in the channels
name exactly the stories here that you
see every day it's you know we're part
of them but everyone here is telling it
you know this is not like a crew in
terms of like just a group of friends
but it's also a crew as far as being
creative partners and collaborators and
working on each other's ideas so the
videos are gonna say the same and the
same great videos that you know and love
and also I mean the banner picture looks
pretty cool and we all look kind of
badass so I mean if you've been watching
since 2011 you know the whole story of
the channel already but if you haven't
it's kind of interesting actually it
actually all started with Nico and
myself just editing together VFX
breakdowns of our videos together I
still find it a little interesting every
once in a while we go back and check
them out because that was one like
literally the Sam and Nico channel was
the two of us filming videos together
actually you know what here's the here's
the crazy thing
every single person working together
here in the studio right now we've known
each other for years through the
weirdest weirdest ways I don't know if
you guys knew this but actually we first
started working with Renton officially
as he filmed behind the scenes for us
back in the day I was in college and I
was like into YouTube and stuff and the
coolest channels Friday be in quarter
digital and I was doing my own visual
effects at the time and so they knew who
I was Emiko knew who I was so I was like
hey I'm in town everyone just happened
to be outside at the time and I was like
they're so with 20 is that Nico is like
sweet see you there
but turns out Nico is in Minnesota at
the time when he tweeted that back to me
so I show up and the only person who
knew I was gonna be there was Henry from
minutephysics
I moved down to LA like two months after
that and I worked on sync and then they
hired me to do ten scenes he was our
first you know experience working with
an editor to kind of create vlog like
stories
the next great leap happened on the set
of shadow of mordor carmichael basically
started joining the team I worked at
star citizen as their main
behind-the-scenes person
RSVP to VHS season 2 premiere where I
met Sam and Nico my good friend Spencer
Jake got me to work at corridor here in
their part-time just sweeping floors
mopping floors helping with shirts
suddenly we were always wait a second
you know this dude edits then I got
offered by Jake to work for a week in
Utah on the shadow of mordor I did it I
came back I got fired for doing it Jake
gave me a full-time job ever since that
was when Jake had that realization that
like wait a second these videos don't
just need to be behind the scenes to be
interesting we can tell stories that are
more than just the ones surrounding
content on the quarter channel that we
make so it's really a Carmichael and
Jake that kind of helped us take that
big push forward with the help of Nick
we've known it for a long time actually
to 2011 when we first started our
YouTube channel he actually helped shoot
shot half of our minecraft video I was
mutual Facebook friends with I think
Nico through Brett driver you like
posted a status back when people did
that thing hey we need a camera for this
video we're shooting but I responded
like hey I have a Canon 7d they're like
cool bring it down yeah it's a Minecraft
video no I think I helped on clock
blockers as well on camera I didn't work
with Samaniego during film school for
about two more years after that Nico
called me up for snapper hero to do
editing and then helped carmichael once
he started the vlogs then started doing
it full-time Christian was like the
first person Jake met when he moved to
Los Angeles or something like that so
when I first moved to LA Jake was moving
into the same complex we became friends
instantly by being neighbors he told me
about this YouTube channel he was
running with his friends I ended up
piaying
on gravity gun and Raymond and I
actually production managed the black
[ __ ] of sass ins Creed video helped build
this studio and build the sound room I
guess that's five or six years later I'm
here full timing and helping run all the
brand stuff and producing all the videos
so you know kind of came full circle
Hadrian straight up was our arch-nemesis
in film competitions on the
internet before we met him in real life
yeah I beat them every single time I
entered any film competition I can I was
entering all these films contests and
stuff and I was seeing these other
videos that were being entered to it
that were just totally blowing ours away
I think I head up Sam I think he was
having a wedding or some things that hey
congratulations and the Sam's like hey
do you want to meet for lunch I'm like
yeah sure let's meet for lunch then we
sat down and we actually got along
really well we had a lot of things in
common and then they're like hey do you
want to direct this division series
no-brainer hell yeah and then from there
they asked me to DP battlefield brush
and then they asked me to DP lifeline
every time we worked on projects
together we just had a really great time
okay so Gabe I'd actually wait I don't
know historian margin story's pretty
simple I worked on snapper hero I walk
into that door and I was like wait I
know this place he started freaking out
inside try to keep it cool Clinton high
video chatted with Clint back in like
2011 too before I even moved to Los
Angeles because he wanted a
recommendation on what camera to buy to
shoot videos with he was on skype with
Freddy and we're all just like talking
about like DSLRs and stuff way back in
the day crazy to think though how like
everyone here actually has years of
history despite all joining the team at
different times at different places you
know under different circumstances the
fact that we've been able to develop
these relationships with all you guys
and everyone in the studio here over the
last few years really demonstrates
strength of this team and it's something
more than any other video I've been
working on on the most proud of so even
though it might seem like a humongous
deal that we have changed the channel
name and art and all this stuff for us
as you've heard it's one of the most
natural steps we've ever done so
consider subscribing if you haven't
already and stay tuned for a much more
great corridor content for the rest of
the year it's gonna be a good one do we
do we do we just call it quarter content
in general or is it separate crew tent
croutons three times
[Laughter]
for those few as you can with the great
names to call the people that watch this
channel croutons